magic it was anything but magical for
tom brady in super bowl 42 against the
giants 17-14 was the final score that
was the year that the
patriots were running up pinball machine
numbers pretty much most of the regular
season
steve spagnolo was the coordinator of
the giants defense that day
oh and spagnolo is the coordinator of
the chiefs defense now
tom brady yesterday when meeting with
the media talked about
facing spagnolo again with the chiefs
defense and has a couple of guys that
could probably give brady a hard time
here's brady talking about that
it's tough you know i think spags runs a
great scheme and i think he really
caters to the strength of his players
and i think his schemes evolved
different times and i've played him
several times over the last
i don't know 13 14 years he's got
i think he's a tremendous coach everyone
seems to love to play for him
and it's a it's a tough game so
i know he's going to have those guys
ready to go they're um
they'll be prepared they got a lot of
great players on that defense a lot of
veterans
a lot of guys who really understand
football um
obviously the moment's not too big for
those guys
you know they've been on the biggest
stage last year and they played a great
game
and beat the niners to win last year's
super bowl so
it's going to be pretty tough
trying to figure out whether that hair
is a fashion statement or just bed head
i don't know i kind of like it though a
little poofy there
for tommy yeah i think that was
intentional though
i think he got all dolled up and wanted
to make sure he looked good for the uh
the press conferences so there's nothing
wrong with that i mean
i'd i'd probably do the same it's
tuesday right
uh well yesterday was not tuesday though
so they didn't have a day off but for a
football player a monday
you know with a week like this could
have been a very easy day for the
players i don't know exactly the
schedule for tampa but
when you've had extra days of practice
already i would think this week is
you know curtailed a little bit and not
exactly your normal week he probably had
some free time to go get a haircut
before he got in there and
and did all his media stuff you know he
also said he's cleared out the house
no one's there it's just him full super
bowl focus
heading into this game he knows what
kind of a challenge it's going to be
he knows that he's got chris jones and
frank clark
to deal with i still vividly recall the
moment in the chiefs patriots game
2019 season when a touchdown i think
would have tied it
so much for clearly recalling it but it
was something like that a touchdown
maybe in a two-pointer would have tired
it
and he had julian edelman open and here
comes frank clark
and that was the old pill bug routine
get rid of the football and curl up in a
ball as anyone with a brain would do
because it's frank clark coming right at
you
and and what did we see against the
bills
it's like every time i looked up chris
jones is busted through
chasing josh allen around and that's how
you you fluster tom brady you get that
pressure up the middle
that offensive line which has held up
very well and it started with the
washington game
they took at the heart when chase young
was talking about you know how he wants
to face tom brady that offensive line
is going to really have to be stout
against jones and clark chris
it is but it has been mike that's that's
the great thing about what they've done
too in tampa
i mean it's unbelievable their offensive
line their past protection we talked
about it last week
you know we didn't even we didn't even
say zadaria smith or preston smith's
name in the green bay packers game
you know they have been phenomenal in
pass protection and even the week before
that
against the great new orleans saints
defense in front and everything they had
to deal with
so i would expect them to be able to
protect the front four
i don't remember jones going off in the
first game
they got great size on that tampa
offensive line
but the spags element is real
and the spags element did get to brady
in the first matchup
and to both of his interceptions one
especially
was pressure related and one was exactly
what you're kind of talking about mike
if you can remember their last
interception
brady gets the ball spags does a
creative blitz off the left side
brady kind of ducks and chucks he's he
doesn't want to get hit right we've
talked about it it's a
hey he's 43. can't be perfect but as
he's doing that
if you remember he's kind of falling
away and fading away and throws the ball
and it goes off of his own lyman's
helmet and then gets intercepted
um so you know spagnolo's ability
to do different things on a weekly basis
disguise
make defenses that are different look
the same
at the snap or right before the snap
that's where he's special and i don't
give a damn if you played quarterback
for 20 years 100 years
or whatever it is he's going to throw
some blitzes and some coverages at you
that you won't be prepared for or that
are going to confuse you
for a split second and maybe throw off
your timing and rhythm and that's going
to be something to watch for for sure in
this one mike
and we know that bruce arians likes to
get the ball down the field the chiefs
defense has been
excellent when it comes to defending the
deep balls 41 percent completion
percentage
that stinks that's first in the league
it stinks for the offenses obviously
10 touchdowns 15 picks and a passer
rating of a paltry 63.3
and you can't even get the ball down the
field
if you can't get rid of the football
because you've been
you know pummeled by frank clark chris
jones or whoever else comes to the party
we saw what happened with the darnell
savage safety blitz between
the packers and the bucks that caused
tom brady to throw one up into the air
that
jair alexander was able to catch and uh
hey the the the chiefs i think
defensively
and and that just like the bucks defense
the chiefs defense gets
overlooked and disregarded because
that's all about the offense that
defense is
is pretty damn good and boy i
i i hope we have a close exciting game
but there's a way this thing goes where
it's 17 nothing again
but instead of 27 24 it's 41 to 10
by the time it's all said and done and i
hope the hell that doesn't happen
i hear you i think that i mean that's
what i think is amazing about the
match-up
i really do i was texting about this
with a little my dad last night but i
i've
similar thought it's just funny you said
it you know i could see the buccaneers
winning the game
certainly but i just think if they win
the game it's going to be a very close
one late field goal type of thing i can
see the chiefs winning the game that way
as well
yeah just like the first one or whatever
but i am with you
i do think there's an element in this
one as unlike
any super bowl i can remember really in
recent history
to where i go this chiefs team
you know you catch them on the wrong day
and make a mistake or two that yeah i
think a blowout
is a possibility in this one i don't
expect it certainly not
um but we know the way that the chiefs
can come out put plays on the you know
put
points on the board and then make plays
on the defensive side of the ball
we've yet to see them really play a
complete really awesome
total football game this year and
i think they realize that they might be
saving it for this weekend and
and you know between the way they're
playing on offense
the health of their secondary mic
because that's the other thing
brady and aryans are going to have to
deal with man
you know the chiefs are a better
secondary you know compared to week 12
with everybody being healthy now
rashad breeland totally back ready to go
you know fenton there legeria sneed the
rookie
they just they're they're an impressive
group back there to where i don't think
they're gonna have to be
totally scared about matching up with
tampa yeah you don't want to do it and
make a living of it
but i i think they can certainly roll
the dice and blitz and live on an island
you know from time to time and have
success
and snead got out of concussion protocol
yesterday so he'll be good to go come
sunday
and yeah think about tom brady in the
super bowl this is number 10 for him the
nine
prior times they were all close games
the only
game that was more than one score was
the 13-3 outcome two years ago against
the rams and that was still a close game
it just wasn't a one score game brady
hasn't blown anyone out
brady hasn't been blown out he knows how
to keep it close he knows how to keep
the doors from flying off
and one of the reasons is he had bill
belichick scheming up the defense brady
yesterday talked about
his time with the patriots and
specifically bill belichick here's brady
on bill
i have a great relationship with him and
uh
again i'm just incredibly grateful for
uh
you know what he's meant in my life uh
as a coach
and um i he was everything you could ask
for as a player
and uh you know i love my time i had two
incredible decades
there and you know my football journey
took me to a different place
and i certainly could never have
accomplished the things in my career
without
his support and his teachings
and incredible coach and mentor for me
and i've had a lot of those in my career
but
obviously he's at the top of the list
easy to take the high road when you're
getting ready for the super bowl and the
other guy's home watching
not that he not i i i just can't help it
because we know we know that
that that tom had had enough
of bill and maybe now with the passage
of time and distance it's easier to
reflect
fondly on it but tom brady had reached
the expiration date he had had his
lifetime
limit of dealing with bill belichick
that's one of the reasons why he left
well i mean yes sure i mean it's not
easy to deal with a head coach that way
for that long
you know and and yes it brings the best
out of you i'm sure brady had points
yeah we're i mean
you know i got to get out of here man
they don't respect me can i get a little
love every now and then that's not the
way the patriots work we know that
that's why brady is who he is
because they didn't do that they made
him tough as hell it was the culture who
made brady i don't care what all the x
players say
okay sorry but he understands that and
even though he'd love to shove it up new
england and belichick's butt and win a
super bowl and an mvp this weekend to go
hey screw you
i did it myself i don't need you guys i
still think tom brady is
very smart very grateful for his time
with bella
bill belichick understands the greatness
of what they did
and i just think as time passes more and
more you know they'll realize how
special it was and
he'll be over this oh i did it without
you and you didn't do it without me type
of stuff
danny amendola made that comment
yesterday on everything just one when
you see patriot way in the dictionary
it's going to have tom brady's name next
to it none of those coaches threw any
passes none of those coaches caught any
passes
they got guys in the right position
because they watch a lot of film and
spend all their time at the facility
tom brady is the patriot way and that's
the reason why tom brady's in the super
bowl right now that doesn't sound like a
bitter player who didn't get kept around
by a coach
i mean no that that sounds like
that sounds like a guy who's about to
become a free agent
and may want to be wearing a pewter
helmet next year that's what it sounds
like to me
frankly yeah well yeah definitely and
you know listen
of course they're both responsible we
know they're both amazing
definitely but the patriot way
and i'll disagree with danny amendola to
the day i die that is ridiculous that he
just said that i mean it's bill
belichick
it's not even close they went to the
first super bowl they didn't even need
tom brady in the afc championship game
he had 145 yards and won in the super
bowl
you know there's there's a number of
games throughout
we know the first three super bowls were
run the ball manage the offense
play defense that wasn't the brady way
that was the belichick
way sorry and then they developed
into hey brady is getting really good
let's infuse the brady way into the
belichick patriot way
and start throwing the ball and
spreading it out so he had a great
culture and coaches to push his buttons
drive him and of course he was willing
to work
and take the abuse from the coaches and
belichick and all that to get better
and that's where it's a beautiful
harmony but
the patriot way starts with one guy and
i don't think
tom brady would even dispute that
i was at that game 19 years ago in
pittsburgh when the patriots came to
town to play the steelers troy brown has
the punt return for a touchdown the
patriot defense
burst the bubble that was the latest
cordell stewart
on a high note you know he would he
would get better and better and better
and then the bubble would pop and he'd
regress
dramatically and then have to build it
all up again but brady got injured in
that game you're right knee injury gone
and and that was one of those years
where there was just one week between
conference championship and super bowl
and
there was a period of time after that
game where it's like well they got to go
with blood so right bro
just got injured he's not going to be
healthy for the super bowl
bledsoe played they won bledsoe's back
after almost getting
killed by moe lewis and uh they they
put that to bed fairly quickly
before it could really take root and
brady was back and
the rest is history so uh we'll see what
kind of history brady
and the buccaneers can make on sunday
against andy reid patrick mahomes and
the kansas city chiefs
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports